Casta and then he slices her face and he
[ __ ] puts her in the whorehouse right
[ __ ] to me yes every our [ __ ] this is
it it's a fourth of July dog get your
[ __ ] together you understand if alex is
Jones is correct we're going to have a
civil war today so what the month you
talked to Alex you gotta calm him down
Alex you gotta calm down talking about a
civil war he had me doing extra Chi but
you the other day I was polishing the
[ __ ] the musket Alex thinks I'm
defending the New World Order cuz I
didn't think that George Soros was a
Nazi it's also painful what's up nothing
everything's great man me too I feel
good Howard Jones I love you buddy
for real but you say some silly [ __ ]
that's where this all comes from doesn't
mean I don't love you you're a great guy
but there's some [ __ ] that's just silly
it's waste of time you know that's one
of those things it's just a waste of
time
does that make sense I'm with you I
think there's real conspiracies you know
but I think there's some that you know
people just get caught up and looking
for conspiracies in everything and after
a while it's exhausting let's get the
ball off the table I love the guy loved
the podcast with Ari last week yesterday
Tina Turner's son he's get Alex Jones
gonna hear this so I'm just I got all
finished okay no it's okay it's just I
love the guy I really do
I just don't support a lot of the [ __ ]
that he said like the Sandy Hook stuff I
don't know if he's since disavowed I
don't know if he changed his opinion on
it I don't know what it is but at a
certain point timing like Jesus man are
you are you sure like you got to be
really sure before you say something
crazy like that right don't you I mean
don't you think look I think he's a
great guy and as a person I'm not
attacking it
I just when he goes crazy and gets mad
at me I love I want to hug him I love Li
told me the story about trotters pulling
up in front of your house and they could
see through your walls they probably
can't do that they do that in different
neighborhoods you know probably can do
something like that but then have to
five of those and this is my experience
they'll tell you something that you got
to sit there and go what the [ __ ] am i
doing sitting here but that's cool
that's Alex when we accept them for what
the [ __ ] he is I just took there was a
civil war started today I really
unprecedented saying what the Democrats
are going at it today so somebody's
shooting somebody's a little [ __ ]
nose so just to calm Alex down nobody's
telling me what to say no one's telling
me what to do not involved in New World
Order who's in the world just because my
enlighten me about the I'm not sure I'm
not involved though I just want Alex to
know not involved little people you can
get it with the other will you the world
daughter who's the dinner people the
people you say you eat with smart oh
they just these are all podcasters and
former professors and all these
different people that are doing
different things together he was
thinking he went back with the CIA what
[ __ ] CBS Radford I think I think in
species are fun and that's part of the
problem with conspiracies they're fun
they're fun to chase down they really
are they're interesting I'll tell you
what's fun to chase down to read about
one and to absorb it by yourself once I
get into am in a room with three men and
we're on a conspiracy for 48 minutes
that's when I get aggravated well that's
what I don't wanna talk about that's
what the [ __ ] that kills me I don't have
the time to discuss with a little moon
landing of that we all have an idea what
we think happened guess what I really
don't want to
not on the [ __ ] 4th of July ya know
the problem with them is and this is a
tendency is that when people get really
into conspiracy theories they're into
everything being a conspiracy it's not
like they're into conspiracy theories
and also into the history of Cuba then
give you a detailed history of some
really crazy [ __ ] that went down like
how many people that are really any
conspiracy theories could give you a
rundown on how Castro took over Cuba
which is like a real thing that happened
in you know our parents lifetimes right
think about that how many people that
are we into like you know whether or not
there's bases on the moon know about you
know all these different things that
have happened through human history the
Mongols the Roman Empire the Greek
Empire it was crazy [ __ ] that definitely
really happened all the stuff that
happened during the Vietnam War all the
stuff that happened during the Nixon
administration all that stuff's real
it's fascinating fascinating [ __ ] to
look into but then you get to dumb ones
like oh god we've really discussed and
whether or not the earth is flat is this
a real conversation my people are really
doing that satellites aren't real going
social me you'll find a bunch of people
to do it'll agree with you - gotta be so
careful about not listening to
scientists